النوم الجيد دون انقطاع وفقا لجدول زمنيا
منتظم امر بالغ الاهميه لصحه الانسان
الجسديه والعقليه لكن هناك الكثير من
الامور التي من شانها ان تعكر صفو نومنا
الضوء الازرق مثلا المنبعث من شاشات
الهواتف المحموله وبعض الاضاءه المنزليه
يسرق النوم من العين ليلا حيث انه يجعل
المرء ويمنعه من النعاس
النظر الى الساعه عند استيقظك في منتصف
الليل فالقلق من مشاهده الساعه يمكن ان
يبقيك مستيقظا لفتره اطول القيلوله اثناء
النهار فالغفوات التي تكون بعد الساعه
الثالثه مساء تحديدا يمكن ان تتداخل مع
فتره النوم في الليل تناول كميه كبيره من
الطعام قبل النوم يمكن ان يسبب انزعاجا في
المعده وكذلك يتداخل مع ايقاع الساعه
البيولوجيه للجسم ما يؤثر على نومنا درجه
حراره الغرفه اذا كانت مرتفعه ستلاحظ انك
تعاني حتى تخلد الى النوم قم بالتاكد من
درجه حراره الغرفه تتراوح بين 23 وال 15
درجه مئويه قبل النوم
القدمان الباردتان قد تكون من الاسباب
التي تعكر صف النوم لديك فبروده القدمين
تسبب انقباض الاوعيه الدمويه وبالتالي تقل
كميه الدم المتدفق ثالثا تدفئه القدمين
قبل النوم يساعد الدماغ في ارسال اشارات
مفهومه الجسم بانه حان وقت النوم ونحن
سالنا الناس في مصر ما اسوا ما يعكر صف
نومك نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
اسوا حاجه بتعكر صفو نومي لما المدام تخش
تصحيني عشان خاطر بتقول لي عايزه فلوس
هم الراجل اللي تعبان ده كل شويه بيعدي
وبتاع فعلا مش عارفه انام منه بقى
[موسيقى]
مثلا هيبقى عليا فلوس طول ما انا عليا
فلوس ممكن ما اعرفش انام بقى بقيه الشهر
كله مش يوم ولا اثنين ولا ما اعرفش انا
الواحد يفكر كتير يابا عليه هموم وعليه
حكايه فبيفكر فيعمل ايه بكره عامه اخواتي
ساعات
هزار بقى مع ضحك ولعب وكده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات